joining me now is Dan Gordon is Israel
Defense Forces reserve duty captain and
Staff Sergeant David bivilla he received
the Medal of Honor for his actions in
the Second Battle of Fallujah also
author of the book remember the ramrods
uh Dan you have fought against Hamas um
you're familiar with with their
tunneling and their tactics and their
techniques what should we expect
here well I think that one of the main
things that you should expect is that
part of hamas's battle plan um as insane
as it sounds to a western audience is to
inflict as much misery as possible on
their own people that's literally part
of their battle plan so the people who
are out there protesting the misery of
the Palestinian people don't realize
they're supporting the very group that
is causing that suffering uh is there
anyone who actually believes that any of
this would be going on if Hamas hadn't
instituted a massacre of is isi citizens
on October 7th the Israelis didn't wake
up on October 6th and say what's on the
calendar for the next three weeks
nothing let's go bomb Gaza this is a
plan of
hamas's uh it is a plan to suck Israel
into a battlefield with in which they
think they can grind up Israeli forces
and at the same time to delegitimize
Israel uh and weaken it internationally
by the use of what Lenin called useful
idiots who as I say in protesting and
support of Hamas are protesting for the
very group that's planning the misery of
the Palestinian people when you see that
with the fabricated stories about the
hospital bombing you see that now with
Israel releasing the fact that hamas's
headquarters are literally located
underneath the largest hospital complex
in Gaza David you've been on the front
lines of some of the most ferocious
fighting American troops have seen in
fuia if you were on the front lines of
what we were what we're seeing here
we're about to see the the initial
incursion what are Israeli troops facing
what does urban combat look like that
they're about to
ensue there's a lot of chaos and you
know the hardest part here is that you
want to imagine this like you're a a
cowboy trying to Wrangle cows you want
to force the enemy where you want them
you want to push them out you want to
smoke them out of where they're trying
to they're trying to fix you inside of a
building they want to neutralize Israeli
Tech technology so you want to dictate
the fight but those tunnels change
everything that sponge bomb that they're
talking about all that's going to do is
try to eliminate them from popping up
behind them Israel wants to push in and
keep the enemy in front what they don't
want is Hamas to jump behind him and
that's where it gets really
chaotic uh Dan did did you train and
plan for tunnel Warfare there are some
reports and there just reports that the
IDF is having challenges access
accessing people who want to be a part
of tunnel units I mean you can imagine
how precarious that assignment would be
how do you train for tunnel
Warfare Israel has uh special units who
are especially the ones who are attached
to combat engineers who train for tunnel
Warfare and almost the entire infantry
trains for it in in one form or another
but you're right as far as the
challenges that you're talking about
you've got an enemy who hides
underground and what you were just
saying is true the that hamas's pentagon
is located underneath shifa Hospital
which is the largest hospital in in Gaza
so you've got an enemy that pops up
shoots at you goes back down and is
trying to suck you into those tunnels to
fight you there and as your other guest
just said Israel's objective is going to
be to try and get them up out of those
tunnels and not go into the Viper Nest
so David let's PR OTE you for a moment
from staff sergeant to General and you
are let's set aside the Strategic
considerations of the balance of will
Hezbollah get involved the the chorus of
the International Community those are
all things you can we we we can
speculate about but we don't know but if
your job is the eradication of Hamas in
for now the north of Gaza how long does
this take how cautious are you does it
surprise you there's been a a three-week
standoff since the attacks of October
7th how do you take this on
so the you know one of the things about
Normandy Beach is you had Omaha you had
Juno you had all these multiple
footholds is what Normandy was the
campaign of the Normandy campaign took
35 days but the foothold is what we talk
about in D-Day there's going to be a
foothold in Gaza but what you're seeing
right now with these operations over the
last four days are just trying to put
multiple Lanes into that City you want
to clear it of IEDs every time Israel
drops a bomb you've created more debris
and one of the things that you're seeing
is a lot of these bombs are hitting
roads and you're getting all those IEDs
everything is wired to blow they they
want to Canal the IDF on the roads they
want them to Traverse IDF has to make
their own roads and if they do this the
way the UN wants if this was 1944 Pete
we put a a kid down there with a
flamethrower it's game set match uh
Hamas knows they can't win Hamas is
going to die they are fighting a losing
fight they're there to kill as many
Israelis as possible and Israel Israel's
job is to be slow this is going to last
for over a month David do you think real
quick exit question Israeli troops will
be given the Rules of Engagement
loosened not loosened Visa known
civilians but the ability to exact
violence on their
enemy I pray to God that Israel is
allowed to defend their way of life and
their country that's just existential
and we we fought it for 20 years Pete
let them win I don't want our grandkids
fighting the enemy that you and I had to
fight Israel is doing this job right now
for the love of God just let them win
there you go Dan Gordon David biva thank
you both for your Insight tonight hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else